شاء وسع كرسيه السماوات والارض ولا يؤوده
حفظهما
العظيم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين
والصلاه والسلام على رسوله الكريم وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله الا
الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
ك رياض الصالحين
الحافظ النووي
رحمه الله تعالى
س الزمر
سوره الزمر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
before
عليه الصلاه والسلامر
[Silence]
ايه الكرسي
سوره البقره سوره الاسراء سوره السجده
سوره الزمر
سوره الملك سوره الكافرون
قران
المعوذت
قل هو الله احد قل اعوذ برب الفلق اعوذ
برب الناسر
عليه الصلاه والسلام
سوره الدخان سوره الواقعه
سوره ياسين
سهمر
importantر
and one of the reasons why heited سوره
الزمر
عليه الصلاه والسلام
[Silence]
‏union
allers
cap
and not
ofutation
from the of the
سهران
all found
صلى الله عليه وسلم
very important
and heitle
عليه الصلاه والسلام
انما يوفى الصابرون اجرهم بغير حساب
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز
انما
ايش يعني انما انما
للحصر
يعني ليس الا
انما يوفى الصابرون اي ليس الا الصابرون
يوفون اجرهم يوم القيامه بغير حساب وز
انما مين
‏reward
on the day of judg without
calalculation without calculation so
what does this mean
well first of all from a logical standpo
it means
‏ifes
the is only those cross the fin
they cross the fin
is only those cross the fin are to those
have some to a
ifes not the finished
الله سبحانه وتالى
without
‏have
no matter how good persons out his race
no matter how good person no matter how
great the is it will only be great if
there is end to if the finish line was
not crossidates
everything how it was
‏What happ to
is invid no matter how good was how
great was no matter how
the person
willate
الله سبحانه وتالى
are enough to have
end to begin who will receive their
reward another as of this verse is that
those who are patient they are the ones
who will receive their reward hence
الله سبحانه وتعالى
that the more person is the more reward
they will
and all of theion of isl
is viewed
اسلام
الله سبحانه وتالى
بغير
حساب ما معنى بغير حساب
قال الحسن البصري رحمه الله تعالى لا يكال
لهم ولا يوزن لهم وانما يحثى لهم حثيا
rather
beondal
وقال تعالى ولمن صبر وغفر ان ذلك لمن عزم
الامور
سبحانه وتعالى
سوره الشং
[Silence]
‏Indeed that tr and
are of the highest order
are
trait number
what
ourings
‏will
any compion any
comp number
haveil
paron to for
why
first of all because we all have dire
need of forgiv
‏will
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمني وكرمه وجوده
ان يلهمني واياكم الصبر والغفران نساله
تعالى ان يجعلني واياكم ممن يوفون
اجرهم
يوم القيامه بغير حساب والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا